nazi germany the final push into the
heart of darkness
the soe had recruited the six of us
under my command for one reason
to retrieve files on the top secret
project phoenix the last gasp of the
third rank
a coalition of allied commandos thrown
together
and aimed at where our enemy was most
vulnerable
this was meant to be
our first and only mission
would you look at that
hell of a world
who's up for saving it
that's vedania
let's go
showtime
jump soldier
what's your uncle
[ __ ] me dead
now that would be properly shot at might
the officer in charge tell us what the
hell we're doing here
that submarine base is our final stop
once we're in we move to secure the
objective he wants us to secure it but
you won't tell us what it is casey's
been dancing around there since the
get-go this ain't just another easter
egg hunt isn't it yeah mate what's a
bloody story we don't quite know
you mean the eso [ __ ] he doesn't
quite know you know what
i'm gonna go pull the prince all we have
is a name
phoenix
so we got no idea what we're up against
that's the mission
to find out
soe says the krauts are moving something
big out of germany
it could be a document stash
the holiest of holies
we are here to pinch it if this is so
important why did they not send an army
they did
there's six of us mate we're not from
the same army hell we're not even from
the same continent quiet get back
why would we chosen for this [ __ ]
suicide mission
brass handpicked six specialists hit the
crowds fast and get away clean an army
can't do that too loud too slow
which is right
they won't see us coming
in and out with those papers before they
know it
do we understand the plan
i shoot nazis they die
that's my plan
[Music]
we missed a hell of a party looks like
they left in a hurry
phoenix we must be close not for long
crowds are moving their stash onto a sub
you see that lot lugging that chest i
bet you london to a brick that is what
we're after
so what are we waiting for time to bring
the heavy stuff now we're talking wait
we can't go in loud
arthur
whatever's in those papers is the best
kept secret in the third reich and the
crowds kept them here in the ass end of
nowhere so why it makes no sense it's
like leaving the crown jewels on the
front porch with hardly anyone watching
them
the entire german army should be
guarding this place
we're not the only ones who don't know
what phoenix is
you're saying nazis are keeping secrets
from nazis i'm saying the ones in charge
of the secrets are the most dangerous
yeah that's why we brought the guns to
shoot them
are we done here those papers are about
to piss off out of germany you three
take the catwalk and make your bloody
noise buy us time web novak you're with
me we'll take the boat
let's go
there's the box
no back you've got a safe cracker he'll
be honest will you
arthur the sirens are stopped that can't
be good we've got to move now go back
help me
[Music]
oh
wait
rectangulus
australia again
i know so
you
get on with it
by delightfully you think you're british
a cambridge man through and through
so
you know better than to
ruin a man's evening
beethoven's sonata has exquisite
but demanding passages that deserve my
full attention
unlike you
does the negro give orders in english
too
and do you follow them
this is
please
proceed
your rhineland accent
you must be from neustadt
during the occupation
you saw french soldiers who look like me
carry guns in your streets
marry your women
that's what i hear
when you speak german
jeremy
we thrashed you once
hear those bombs
that's us thrashing you again
what an interesting choice of words
i told you already
get on with it
yes
that's what you want
to sacrifice yourself
to be a
leader
i am not here to give you what you want
quite a concert
[Music]
what you say
[Music]
dispose of it
put the rest in the truck
no back
jesus christ
people die
people die when command [ __ ] up
how exactly is this arthur's fault
this is on him
and on wade and bastard abandoning his
team
well you're right about wait
if he shows his face again i'm bloody
killing myself oh yes let's keep blaming
each other instead of the germans
is that supposed to impress me relax
it does not matter
verizinger is going to kill us all
the nazi
the one who killed novak old friend of
yours is he
we have history oh yeah what kind of
against fryzinger
arthur will get us out of this
what because he's your mate
it wasn't always
but i've seen him in action
you lose men
that's war
sometimes the only way to honor a fallen
soldier is to finish the mission
but try remembering that
while their blood stains your boots
if you're meant to lead you have to
learn what it's like to lose men
to have them die trusting you
and there's only one way to learn that
lesson
first time i did
was on d-day
and it seems like the crowds already
know we're coming
now we've got one chance to demolish the
coastal artillery
but if we don't the invasion tomorrow
will fail now i trade you all for this
let's not let the navy show us up
so take the case mates
blast the artillery and the fireflies to
let them make you know the job's done
all right this is it
you know the drill
stand up
hook
oh
ugh
uh
hey
nice to see you gents where do we stand
the captain didn't make it so we're on
our own now
i say we dig in and wait for the rest of
the sick airborne to assemble henry said
we had till dawn to destroy the
artillery if we don't the invasion fails
so you fancy yourself the captain now
sun-up's an hour away at best there's no
time for a sit-down yeah there's also no
muscle and no cavalry coming to save the
bloody day
the only thing we can do here is to die
or try not to you two scrapping i've
always got the bigger bollocks ain't
gonna solve nothing those german
casemates aren't that far away i think
we can get to them in time so i say we
take them out the companies scattered
we're pissing in the wind at this point
i know what's a snake
you all do this is madness hey we're
beyond madness
look i'm with arthur
we finished the mission
all right kingsley
looks like you're in charge now
casemates and valhalla
are that way
all right let's move it everyone on that
transport
who remembers how to drive a blitz i got
this serge
[Music]
well that was a [ __ ] kerfuffle
hey sarge got it done
still here aren't we i suppose
eight men standing against the nazi
gunfort
richard said i got mad
sometimes
a little madness is called for
i think deep down he understood that
and realized
we were cut from the same cloth
how's it looking sergeant let's see for
yourself
let's get you the lay of the land
our targets are the guns housed in those
casemates and we can only get there
through a horde of germans armed to the
teeth
i think you can handle taking out the
lower gun
i fancy my chances
that bunker's our way in
but it's packed with mg's it'll be a
hard push
first job's getting across that
minefield
but that anti-tank ditch could be useful
i've got an idea i'm always we can punch
a hole through the mines with those
blitzers there and the bunker will make
minced meat out to us as soon as they
hear the engines coming we're going
quiet then no engines better the last
second let gravity do the work
that should get us to the ditch at least
well
i love it
i think you should go first
all right then as soon as you hit the
ditch get the men ready
tommy you with me
oh yeah drive through the minefield take
the bunker strap some thermite to some
highly explosive weapons
piece of piss sarge
can you
get a second sun burning in the sky if
our ships don't see that flare if they
don't know we've won they'll fire on the
guns and risk taking us with them
well i don't know about you but i think
i'll take very little consolation in
knowing that the fire that killed me was
friendly don't worry gov
i won't forget to wake him up
sergeant the flare bombardment any
minute
damn
players ruptured you got it
where's webb
there lower case mate
we need to run for it
what
where the hell have you been
finding time to take a kip
i was just waiting for some outcaster to
come and save the day well unless you
and i signal our boy shall we
[Applause]
we lost our captain but we'd won the day
and we'd honored the memory of all those
we lost
the only way we could
by completing the mission
you look at the soldiers under your
command
and hope that they can do the difficult
thing the impossible thing that flare
told me i'd been right
this
is what it means to be a leader
[Music]
from all the flags waving on the streets
we'd never have known the nazis were
about to lose the war
but bullies are always loudest when
they're scared
and when they're desperate
they get stupid
commander herman freisinger had killed
novak they'd given us a free ride
right into the lion's den
[Music]
read the field report
twice
this ally team is fascinating they have
been captured
but it was too close
i want you to find out everything you
can about this unit
it will be my pleasure sir
you will speak of this to no one else
and report directly to me
alright it is everyone this prison is
now our battlefield
all right christ what is that smell
chlorine dioxide
they think it hides the smell of death
well this is the nicest [ __ ] i've
ever been in
is anyone else hungry
so i am happy term fiora richter and
piss off crowd
unless you've got room service for us
and i have questions for you
yeah we can always bloody questions i'm
the commanding officer
you'll speak with me
even then richter was easy to read
uniforms at high rank no compact medals
office rat
the perfect mark
surrounded by three guards all armed
and all wankers
in all my years studying the allies i
have never come across such an unusual
unit
kingsley
arthur
lieutenant
service number two five two three two
six four two
i'll tell you a story
i have spoken with zafura on exactly one
occasion
he recommended a book to me
the passing of the great race
by an american
a man named madison grant
shifura had nothing but trace for him
[ __ ] madison grant
and everyone like him
the book reveals that under extreme
duress
or
unfavorable conditions your people
do not deteriorate so easily
in that moment
i knew what i had to do
write to the super stone or notch
below the clavicle
once we had what we needed from this
racist bastard
that's
where i would put my knife
my plan began to take shape
we were being held in the basement of
gestapo headquarters
around and above us was a treasure trove
of classified nazi intelligence
project phoenix had to be there
somewhere
and richter was our ticket
he thought he was the interrogator
if he was to be of any use to us
he'd have to keep thinking that
that arrogant nazi in his clean pressed
uniform loved the sound of his own voice
the hard part wouldn't be fooling
richter into spilling what he knew of
project phoenix
the hard part
would be convincing the others
not to kill him first
the allies somehow knew about project
phoenix
we must have a traitor amongst the
officers
i pulled their files
take care of them
with the other
non-essentials
lieutenant kings they mentioned a
project phoenix
likely allied propaganda
the negro thought he was protecting his
team
no doubt to prove himself
to make him their leader
the allies must have been desperate
he said it was their first mission
that his sixth man is dead
he's probably lying
i will uncover the truth
are there other teams like this one
how did they learn of hamburg
is temple half at risk of being
compromised these are the things i need
to know
there's more stake here than i'm at
liberty to discuss
just know
that i'm counting on you
hey richter
i understand
thank you
so
uh
well i see ten fingers
that's a good sign at least don't make a
bus
i'm fine
listen
they know about wade
but they haven't caught him yet
i told him he was killed didn't you
on the train to hamburg
i don't think they'll fall for it but
the hope is it'll buy him some time to
get us out
he isn't coming back for us she's right
kingsley we can't count on that [ __ ]
drongo
bring out the girl
she i got nowhere man
i'll just get out of my way
is
[Music]
every person on this team was a hero in
their own right
long before their files ever reached my
desk
but to say they were strong
personalities would be
a vast understatement
particularly when it came to petrova
have you seen my
again
it's bad enough i have to wear this
thing at all no it's flammable
that's here's teaching me how to shoot
wasted
stuck in a med tent
don't be in a rush to fight deutsche
glory is worth nothing
when you are dead but this fight
it matters you
matter you and me sir
are all i have left
[Music]
hey
be nice
i'm always nice
felicia
what do you got there
empty bottles i'm training fresh parties
our cameras already know how to drink
these will be molotov soon is it wise to
give explosives to civilians
you worry too much
[Music]
oh there
isn't that nice
a real family breakfast
bombs and bullets best way to start the
day
you know you're gonna get yourself
killed having that old rifle in the
house for russia
now who is worried too much
so
the germans are approaching the front
line
is that where you're off to
no
i told me that's not what i'd be the
most useful so
i'm training recruits at the old post
office
must be nice
it would have been nice to have a choice
under that
at least you get to follow don't tell me
at least you what's it
you're both doing your part
which reminds me
if any of those who brutally get past
you
you know where to send them
of course
they will never get through
never
building i need to run there waiting for
me miss your
box
i swear he would forget to keep his own
head screwed on without us
we really are saints
honestly
i'll make sure he gets this on my way to
the med tents
you help your country much more than you
know
and you make your old man proud
forget something
you're a life saver you know
mr speaker
i should be going with you you probably
should i have more practice than any of
these red army
keep your voice down
you don't want to make enemies here fine
just
don't do anything i wouldn't do couldn't
even if i tried my aim is [ __ ] compared
to you
it's too bad we can trade places that
would look great in that uniform
at least try to make it back from your
palm making
one piece several pieces it's fine i'm
pretty good at putting people back
together yes
you've made me late again
i'll have to take the rooftops you're
gonna get yourself killed climbing
around up there
i promise you can say i told you so if
it happens
now go
go
tribitrova will need you down by the
first stand plenty of men that you're
catching up today go ahead join the
others
oh god
[Music]
ugh
yes
[Music]
god
you help your country
more than you know
and you make your own man proud
[Music]
i should have been here
[Music]
take care of each other
[Music]
uh
well mom i'm off to save misha
as usual
i think they're dead can you get us free
now
it was incredible we're going
now
well i i was so scared that you and me
you're the one tied up
take care of the others
hop up
he's gone
no we don't have time for this
we have to get your recruits out of here
if we stay here much longer we're
trapped
you're right
you're right
okay
let's go
[Music]
misha we need to get to the volca how do
we get out of this building
misha focus
how can we escape to the river
there's an exit here we could make a run
for the sewers
but the germans are blocking the court
here it'll be tough
do you have any extra supplies weapons
anything i can use i know there were
soldiers defending on the roof they had
a radio there might be supplies too all
right i'll lay down cover fire from
there while you get our people to the
sewers if you're sure sister maybe you
can reach the roof climbing up there
that should get you to the roof i'll
give you a boost i'll find a good place
to cover you i know
always been a better shot than me
is with me now
and i know he wouldn't want us to die in
this post office to a bunch of obliotke
he would be proud of you
he would be proud of us
get our people to this door
i'll lay them fire from the roof
don't miss okay i never do
surviving stalingrad was no small feat
escaping
even greater
but no one really escaped something like
that
the nazi war machine had touched all our
lives
burned away something important
i think that's what made us attractive
to the soe in the first place
but for polina
the wound was marrow deep
she was destined to return the favor
and that had made her
the deadliest member of my team
[Music]
such a touching story
you couldn't even save the life of your
own father
so tell me
why isn't ivan with an old rifle part of
a top-secret allied operation
you do not scare me
little mouse
you misunderstand me for a line
i do not need you to fear me
i need only your screams
that will convince your friends to talk
why
because i am a woman
tell me
what other missions the allies have
in germany
nothing more talking about
so
what is worth talking about proline
rising
go fetch him
i'll confirm my story together
take her back
send me all the records on a commander
steiner
and any photographs of the russian
sniper
lady nightingale yes is that one
and
yeah frightener
i was just coming to see you
we have confirmation from the woman
the sixth ally is dead
is that soul
an american
arrested at temple half
trying to steal a plane
this makes no sense
the prisoners made a fool of you richter
and now you have made a fool of me
the american is being brought here now
if i must interrogate him myself
then i have no use for you
you hurt are you blind
just trying to be nice
what did you tell them
we treated torture tips
relax
i told the same lies as you did he
believe you i stopped asking when i
brought up frysinger
when we get out of here
the first thing i'm going to do
is head to the pictures
let it
break my heart all over again
then you lucas
what's the first thing you'll do when
we're out of here
when i get home
i'm eating lamingtons for a week
all cakes all the time
i know what you miss yeah
i'd like to have that sweet bird barbara
pull me pints of my local until i forget
the symphony war ever happened
i don't even know if she's still alive
everyone i love is dead
and the only time i feel anything is
when i watch a german beg for his life
so
i am exactly where i need to be
wade showed up just as i'd hoped
he played his part well without even
knowing my plan
the team had written him off
but i was counting on him being his
usual charming self
try that again crowd and we're gonna
have a real [ __ ] problem
your team lied about you
lieutenant
lieutenant
now is that so hard
finally some respect
i know you're the sixth man
what did you want with that plane
you nazis
you make me miss fighting in the
stinking pacific
i want to know what else they've lied
about
wade had talked himself out of worse
situations
if you heard him talk about midway
you could tell he was no stranger to
hyperbole
every time wade told the story it was a
little different
he added a wing of zeros or another
aircraft carrier to his tally
but i read the reports about what
happened that day
if wade was exaggerating
it was only by a little
a little further
now jackson
[Music]
wade would rather have been called a hot
shot than a hero
that was his contradiction
he is one of the war's greatest pilots
but he needed a team
the problem was
getting him to admit
[Music]
hey guys
don't everybody rush over at once
isn't this a nice little reunion
you lied to me
for all we knew he was dead
so you can [ __ ] off
really
do not lie to me again
what is going on
hitler is dead
what
reports indicate he
took his own life
but
without the fuhrer
we were lost
hardly
i trust you have new information
as you suspected
see american
was the sixth man
but i believe i have finally broken him
it saddens me
to see the fatherland divine
i feel the russians
there's nothing left for us here
if the right is to live on
i must know their safe passage to temple
love
i was counting on you
richter
but we've proven non-essential
no
no no sir no i will get you what you
require i sweat
your time is short
i understand
my fear
i'm gonna kill him
the rector is on to us we're out of time
i uh
i tried to navigate away playing but
that didn't work
and by the time i got here
you guys were already locked up
so
i i borrowed a bomb from the rooskies
and turned myself in we got about uh
about an hour before that wall blows
wide open and we waltz right out of here
if we live that long
we can't trust him
he's just a [ __ ] pilot a [ __ ] ace
pilot is what you mean i'm with the lady
what the hell do you know about
explosives yeah well [ __ ] you too then
i'll tell you why we can trust him
here we go
wade's more than capable of getting us
out files it earned
we've got company
hang on back there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[ __ ]
when wade was airborne he was the most
dangerous thing in the skies
but if you fly too close to the sun
eventually
your wings will get burned
stupid son of a [ __ ]
you could have gotten us both
oh [ __ ]
all right
okay
i'll get you out of here but it's gonna
hurt like how
i need to find out where we are so i'm
gonna have to leave you here
think about the yankees
all right
you know i'm a doctor
i need your gun
i
lost mine in the crash
the one you caused
what am i supposed to do
keep yourself bandaged up
i don't want you bleeding out and
missing all the fun
stay out of sight till i get back
is
wait
[Music]
do you speak japanese
[Music]
ah
[ __ ] up
they're still alive yeah
no [ __ ] got them free
i'm aviation machinist mate third class
hernandez the ungrateful ones lieutenant
jackson we got shot down that's why
we're here thanks
sergeant james washington army 93rd
infantry division lenny pastor's man up
you got any plans
we need to get back up there flames
we lucky they gave us him
that one's dead weight
just gonna slow us down yeah i'm right
here
you know how to use a gun went through
basic just like you
start with that company
i gotta control the stick now lieutenant
you're just someone for the ride
[Applause]
all right
let's get moving
hernandez
[Applause]
hernandez you're with me
welcome
howard you're a dragon
once we clear the wire we'll build a
heavy fire i need you to turn up the
heat on these bastards you got it sarge
jackson a word
yeah you're gonna help private howard
get that wire
and then
you're gonna keep him covered on the
other side understood
look
in the sky i'm your man but this
i'm not the die face down in the mud
type then you shouldn't get yourself
shot down
there's a difference between suicide
and sacrifice
you do well to learn it
belfry shoot the flare let's see him
stop us now are you [ __ ] crazy why
would you fire that here he just gave
the entire japanese army our location
the invites not for them is for the rest
of my men
right on schedule
lieutenant come take a look at this
[Applause]
here come my boys can they finish the
job check out the hangar
near the radio tower
valdo you know anyone can fly it this
was your plan all along
my man can take the base
slow down the japanese
but if we had someone in the air
wouldn't that be something i'm your man
sergeant
i was hoping you would say that
let's get down there
do you even know how to land that thing
has that ever stopped me
let's go regroup with the tanks
get in that cockpit
yes showtime wade
we'll push you out of the hangar
take this
cover us while we get you in position
find us some runway and we'll handle the
rest
put your facts into it
push
keep
show us what you can do lieutenant
all right
let's see do we have enough runway yeah
more or less i should have known you'd
say that
here we go
stay behind the tank
[Music]
[Music]
come on let's go
the men of the 93rd
changed wade they showed the flying
daredevil from the clouds
what war looked like in the dirt
down there
he learned the only way to win was to
have each other's backs
if you get past this talk and you see
his actions
you know
who a jackson really is
i don't care what he did before
wade abandoned us in hamburg
i still don't trust him i get it
but we're not in this [ __ ] because
of him
we're in this [ __ ] because some
sodding krauts think they can crack the
best team i've ever worked with
now
we need a plan to get us out of here
we're surrounded by nazis even if we
escape we're gonna be dead before we
reach the door
maybe not
what an idea
we were gonna put on a show for richter
it was a gamble
but we'd come too far to give up on
getting those files
paulina being next gave us time to get
ready
we knew she'd held her own
nice to see you again fallen
please
please
this is exactly what i imagined your
weird little office would look like
[Music]
tell me what your team is planning
lady nightingale
[Music]
stalingrad
the city that arrested the nazis eastern
expansion
had the city fallen
russia
would have crumbled
the germans
underestimated russia's will to survive
they underestimated the city
and her defenders
the people looked to polina as a symbol
of hope
but she didn't want to be a hero
she wanted only vengeance
[Music]
the arrogance of the third reich was to
think they could achieve was a great
napoleon could not
if they weren't facing someone as fierce
as lady nightingale
there
you heard stan has been creeping around
the commercial district makes sense it's
never far from the slaughter
let's go and wait but we should see who
the earth with another family is now
knife
short
that's a sniper shot precise
but you think this they might be okay
there's more cover this way
come on
i can't wait to put a bullet for
steiner's head
wait
this is bad for lina
we can't strike from here there's too
many of them take a look
[ __ ]
there on the right
sniper get down
we don't have time for this sister you
hear me i need to get you somewhere safe
to punch you up
you're not going to die here
up
let's move
watch out
[Applause]
you cover the opening i go out and flank
them there is no attack
i will slow down
oh
i know you are here somewhere
you will not get away this time
[Music]
you are nothing without your rifle lady
nightingale
you are exactly where i want you
carry along
[Music]
[Music]
you won't find satisfaction in this
it won't end with me
we'll destroy you all
you won't be doing anything
not me
yeah
hey singer
he will finish what he started
what you've left me is this night
i could
help you
incredible
you're all the same
i've killed more of you than i can count
and you all spout the same pathetic
[ __ ]
rising
is he supposed to scare me another piece
of fascist filth
don't worry
i'll hunt him down next
you thought you'd take my city and crush
my people
you tried to break me
but you failed
you created lady nightingale
and now
she's destroyed you
know
the infamous lady nightingale brought
stalingrad back from the brink
her actions inspired the russians to
take back their city and go on the
offensive
[Applause]
polina changed the course of the war for
the allies and her people
with that reputation
it was only a matter of time before we
found her
what would frysinger want with a lowly
officer on the eastern front what does
it matter
it matters
a great deal to me fraulein
[Music]
nice lighter
[Applause]
from what i could gather
fryzinger was recruiting steiner for
some special project
project phoenix
could be
i know is
i was sent to kale rising
here there's got to be a better way out
of here
there is no way out of here
unless of course
you have decided to do the intelligent
thing
open that door back up and i'll show you
the intelligent thing
you can get me out alive what i can
you two-face bastard
all right
i'll tell you what you want to know
typical aussie no honor no loyalty
gonna be the next sacrifice in your
crusade tommy
i hope your plan was worth it
break her leg lucas
i thought you'd be the one to put an end
to your team's foolish agent
you killing each other now
i know why you chose to cooperate
i would not take orders from any growers
you got it all wrong mate
i don't follow
i don't care what color his skin is
haven't you heard about the aussies and
the brutes
we were the pieces of [ __ ] flushed down
the crown's dunny yes yes of course but
your nations are allies
it was more like master servant
i did what i did because to every brit
folks like me are expendable
insubordinate
churlish
no stranger to a prison cell
that's lucas
you had to credit the soe
they were very good at spotting talent
in the unlikeliest of places
and lucas had talent
he was a skilled demolitionist with an
explosive temperament
and a sharp tongue
out there in the desert the rats of to
brook were like a family
unfortunately they never did figure out
how to get along with the brass
today princess
i'm savouring the moment
i'm so sorry of course you are your
highness hey bluey wake up you're gonna
want to see this one
oh [ __ ] me play the damn cards
all right this
read him and wait oh you [ __ ] donkey
no way why are the bloody hell on you at
your post by your hands
major
convoy's approaching right
you rats follow me
try and act like real soldiers for once
sir
oh
yes
see that's what a real soldier looks
like mate
what a way to stand up to him bluey
good job buddy [ __ ] off dez what's going
doing here in the first place huh he's a
major he can do whatever he wants
you're lucky
i was about to make me come back
shut up dez you've never beat me at
anything what
ah mate paul the other one
the explosives are ready
lucas and i set them ourselves
sir
man your position
the timing must be perfect i need you
all to focus
we've got eyes on them
quiet over there hang on now what's that
in the lead be
quiet i'll do the honors thing yep sir
mark is that first rock yes i know
that's a tank
germans have tanks private but the arm
is too thick we didn't pack for a tank
hit the treads it's the only way you're
going to stop it i i need to focus sir
wait for the treads no no wait
i'm distracted
they think it's a mine
pop it up crowd
[Applause]
he's tired
didn't get very far this was a simple
raid and half the supplies we wanted
have gone up in smoke sir there's still
one truck down the ridge well then take
some rats and get after them jacobs
let's go thank you for sniffing around
the dirt
now that's how you win a war
but then we're leaving
hey i found something
you read kraut a little of course he
does
it looks like one of romney's officers
checked through here to visit a camp up
the way i don't know what kind i don't
recognize these symbols
then we go take a look
the krauts just lit up the sky more
could be coming no we return to base
report to the major we can't report a
thing if we don't know what it is
that wouldn't be good soldiering jacobs
fine
we'll scope it out
let's trade quietly this time
where is everybody
probably out looking for us i reckon
hold on what's all this
who cares
look at this
i think the chap on the left is wrong
who's the fancy bugger seriously
we're gathering intelligence something
you obviously lack private hilarious
you sought your papers you know what i
see i see a ton of [ __ ] outside that
goes boom now what do you suppose we
should do about that well we should blow
it the [ __ ] up
that's what i call target rich
wait
you guys hear that
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
on the coast of italian libya an
australian private and a group of rats
had given rommel a huge black eye
their action should have earned them
medals
and maybe even a shred of respect
hams
didn't see it that way
their reward
was some time in the brig
however all richter seemed to care about
was rommel and his connection to
fraizinger
that fool would listen to lucas as long
as we needed him too
what was the rest
we have very little time tell me what
did frysinger want with rommel
i thought you wanted to know about our
team answer me now or our deal is off
okay okay
don't get your undies in a twist
lucas piled it on like a chap
he didn't have to tell richter anything
more than the lies that nazi already
told himself
that was the third reich for you
their reality
was delusion
[Music]
you'd think we'd need a miracle for
lucas to pull this off
the thing is
he was like a magnet for that kind of
luck
there's that saying about lightning
striking twice
yet lucas had managed to find himself
first and to brook and then at el
alamein
the world knew of an allied victory in
north africa
but it wasn't because of british
commanders or mighty tanks
lucas had the untold story
and richter was eating it up
[Music]
have's got himself a big sniffy today he
must smell a promotion
after the intel that we dropped on that
wanker
this is the plan that he comes up with
buckley's chance is gonna work what's he
saying jacobs
oh he's personally thanking you and dez
for being stand up chaps it's stuffed
it's king and country
it's always king and country
bloody hell is that what i think it is
where'd you swipe that from
i found it lying around
he catches you with that you're a dead
man
i'll drink to that
return fire
[Music]
wake up mate
oh [ __ ] oh
we are being torn apart i gave you an
order form the perimeter protect the
armor sir you got to be bloody joking we
will hold this line our air support is
[ __ ] if we don't deal with those flat
cannons there's not gonna be a [ __ ]
line you have your orders
flag of the order
we are taking that hill alone yeah i got
me and i got tears [ __ ]
here
take this you clear those flat cannons
shoot this flare nice and high then i
know to radio our bombers
good luck
let's go
i hope jake it's a blue he can hold out
help me with this mg
[Music]
there
there's fire the flare
i didn't expect today to end like this
it why not
let's do this
as usual i'll do all the work
sometimes
the only way to honor a fallen soldier
is to finish the mission
but try remembering that
while their blood stains your boots
that's what i told lucas when we first
met
war
had taught us both that lesson
[Music]
the rigid hierarchy of allied command
would look at lucas and see only
character flaws
insubordinate
childish
no stranger to a prison cell
he was perfect for my team
even if he does
have a mean right hook
[Music]
lucas played his role perfectly
he had ricker distracted and doubting
everything he thought he knew
are you all right mate you you're
looking a little bit pastier than usual
please
this was
this
was
never about winnings a war
this was never about winnings at
a
all
this was a cool
temple off
that's how he's getting some out
taking sarai underground
and wait a minute
you're not part of the plan are you
well it looks like we're both going to
end up on that meat pile back there
one thing i learned studying allied
strategy
redundancy
always have a plan b
with the soviets invading the city
lady nightingale will be my leverage
i will exchange her for my own safe
passage
well that's one hell of a plan fritz
it probably would have worked
[ __ ] way
no please
i won't let you go
you made one mistake but it was a bloody
ripper
you thought you practiced
redundancy mate
always have a plan b
[Music]
i've just received word
we have safe passage from berlin
three years we have waited for this
moment
many good men were lost
but i promised you
project phoenix would succeed
hitler has paid for his weakness
and now history will remember him as we
do
a failure
and a coward
the red army is nearly upon us
and berlin is burning
but from the ashes shall rise
our vision for something greater
[Applause]
hey boss
your plan worth
hey there buddy
remember me
[Music]
looks like you got a fan
what do we do with them
i can think of a few things
figured you'd want the honest boss
no
no this is your chance
project phoenix
i can get used to evidence
shh
you've already done your part
right of the super stone notch
below the clavicle
that's where richard
so
goodbye little mouse
[Music]
richter thinks pricing a cute hitler
yeah he's taking the right underground
how's it getting out temple off airport
look
we can get out
right now get ourselves on the first
transport be home in time for supper
oh
we can end this hunt now perisinger bury
the right for good
we might not make it out of berlin
but neither will the nazis
whatever we do though we do it together
risinger is not leaving portland
surprise me lamingtons can white
wait
hey
it's not every day you get a chance to
kill a fur
can't turn that [ __ ] down right
after you
lady nightingale
just so you know
i still haven't ruled out killing you
all
[Music]
let's go boss
can you catch up surprising guy
yeah this is a tough car not a hot rod
i just need to see the back of his head
tough shot we taking beds how
in here
something big coming up
[Music]
cover you wait
sounds like they expected us hey lucas
you got a banger for me giving me best
[Music]
aah
if i never see berlin again it'll be too
soon
i can't believe i'm agreeing with you on
something i'm glad we're all getting
along
rising is right out of here can't be far
this is it
our final innings
let's get this bastard for novak and for
richard
this ends today
it's time
[Music]
[Music]
it's over
[Laughter]
[Music]
you cannot kill me
and yet here we are
and even the allies
would leave their decision so inferior
such as yourself we need him alive boss
the intel he's got what we came for hey
shoot him or bring him i'm starting this
plane
he'll never talk
get up
donations will make sure i'm well taken
care of
as payment for my cooperation
peaceful new beginning
life of american luxury
might suit me
perhaps i might even start a new family
not for you
there is no starting over
do you even know who i
am the value that i can provide
you're not worth it
suppose that's it then
let's go
how we looking out there gonna be dicey
just so i like it
[Music]
hi we're back in business
that's it
let's take a
look the cape verde islands the bahamas
argentina even antarctica
christ
these bastards have been plotting covert
operations all over the world
around our noses
are you like
get this uganda
here we go
[Music]
we hit the bloody jackpot
[Music]
come on
dig in
[Music]
how about this
project nova
i can beat it
project ether
reviving the dead
does anyone want some nazi gold
looks like we're going to be busy
keep going
open them all
here we are just about to try this
autopilot and come back
what's project aggregate secret v2
rocket facility
you think you could play one of those
i could fly anything
hang on back there
[ __ ] wait
our mission was complete
but there'd be more
forged in the fires we were the tip of
the spear
we
were the vanguard
you